these guys on a daily basis assess this
they target with this system you can
shoot an Al-Qaeda or an Isis tire out of
a moving vehicle you can track it and
Target it at 23 miles or more and it
it's never failed the system that's why
it's so high fidelity high quality
thermal it's never failed they track it
and they blow up and Return to Sender
bombs so if somebody puts like a bomb on
a drone and it over the wall an
incursion right first time the world is
ever seeing an incursion of a true UAP
designated by our government in a
conflict Zone first time we get footage
of that film by the military that's what
you're seeing now the problem is is that
they couldn't lock the system that they
believe it was active jamming the people
that were there that day they believe
that this object was um somehow
inhibiting their targeting system from
blocking so they they had to optically
slew the camera optically follow it
which is a big part of the story right
but yes they blow up and they Return to
Sender it's a really funny term they use
uh the bombs that come over and it's a
real danger bunny style return to Center
bro you're bringing me a bomb take it
back and sign for it bam you know so
anyway so that's what you're seeing now
it is the strangest morphology you know
shape of a uo that I've ever seen the
jellyfish the jelly and I call it the
jellyfish because of what it did at the
end which I have not provided footage
for yet but it did something it went
trans medium went into the water we'll
talk about that in a sec but the shape
of it let's just talk about that why we
call it the jellyfish some people on
bass were calling it The Spaghetti
Monster right so here's the deal the
jellyfish morphology of UFOs has been
reported since the beginning of UFO
sightings just because you haven't seen
it doesn't mean it that that's a new
thing if you look at like a John Keel
book called operation Trojan horse one
of the first shapes he lists for known
UFOs is jellyfish the reason that I
dubbed that rather than the spaghetti
monster which was pretty cool is because
it went into the water so what you're
not seeing in the footage I provided and
maybe one day that footage will go
public today is not that day but I will
tell you it does and was filmed and the
object does this it goes out over Lake
havania if I'm saying it right it stops
on a dime it descends stiff into the
water and for 17 minutes operators were
told to track the area so they did they
panned out they watched the object does
a controlled us scent up out of the
water after 17 minutes and then shoots
off at 45° it wasn't instantaneous
motion but it was a rapid acceleration
to the point where the camera couldn't
track it anymore after like 30 miles
away that did happen there is footage of
it and I do hope that one day people get
to see that I am not in a position to
release that but I am testifying to you
and take that for whatever you want that
footage exist why not what are you
waiting for
yeah I am going to so I don't have that
footage it's not in the safe I'm going
back what safe
I I don't I I don't have that footage to
provide to the public uh however I know
precisely where it exists and I will be
informing people within government
exactly where to look people that have
been lied to I will be doing that
straight up and then it's up to them can
they declassify can they get it out but
I will be doing
that